طلبت بالتغيير
بس ما حدا نجاوب ليش بدي ابلش انا انه
طالب بالتغيير ليش ما ببلشوا انا لحالك
امام نافذه تطل على الزبائن يقف فيها
لتسلمي بضائعهم هي عباره عن مقتنيات
يمتلكها الجميع لكن قله تفكر باستثمارها
اطنان من النفايات يتخلى عنها اللبنانيون
مقابل المال في خضم ازمتهم الاقتصاديه
حينا او يتبرعون بمردودها لاطفال مرضى
السرطان احيانا هكذا ابتكر بيار حلا يرضي
الجميع
وباستثمار مني بسيارتي بلشت استثمرت بوقتي
وبحاله نحن نبغى الربح وعم نربح
هي طريقه لحتى نحمي البيئه غير انه كل شيء
وثاني شيء انه طريقه لحتى نقدر نحن الشباب
هم بلبنان شو عم نقدر نطلع كتير مصاري سوق
لحتى نقدر نطلع شوي مصاري زياده
شجع فيها المواطنين على فرز النفايات في
منازلهم وقد فاق عدد الزبائن توقعات
الشركه التي سارعت الى افتتاح فرع سان لها
خلال اشهر كل تعني النفايات عم بيجي لعنا
عم نكون عم نخفف عن الدوله 60 دولار للطمه
هذا اقل ما فينا نقوله نحن بهاي الفرع
لحاله بثلاثه اشهر اكثر من 43 طن تخيلوا
المبلغ اللي قدرنا نوفره على الدوله
بالاضافه للدوره الاقتصاديه اللي خلقناها
منها المواد ومنها التوظيفات قدرنا نعمل
من اسبوع بمتابعه مكثفه مع وزير البيئه
افتتاح لعشر مراكز ضمن بلديه بيروت
بالتعاون مع البنك الدولي بهبها اجت منه
وراح يشرفوا عليها اليو ان دي بي
في معمل متواضع تعالج النفايات حيث تكبس
وتفرم وتعجن قبل ان يعاد بيعها لمصانع
محليه اما الفائض فيصدر الى مصر وتركيا
ودول اوروبيه
مره جديده تثبت المبادرات الخاصه قدرتها
على التفوق على الدوله لاختلاق حلول
لازمات يدفع ثمنها اللبنانيون غنوه يتيم
العربيه بيروت لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات